[Musique]
bernard tapie s'est donc éteint à l'âge
de 78 ans au revoir mon phoenix écrit
son fils stéphane sur les réseaux
sociaux c'est une figure qui a
incroyablement marqué la société
française
avec à la fois ses côtés
discutez polémique ces quinze jours
après 28 ans vous allez comprendre ça
les entreprises qui a acheté était morte
je compte y prônait une boîte et qui
avait mille personnes si on enlevait
370 qui était sauvé imaginez une
synthèse de bébelles de johnny l'idée de
dolo qui en plus ce serait 1 3 mais
n'est-ce dans la ville
faisant la la la la la transatlantique
pilote automobile patron d'une équipe de
vélo deux styles et est champion
d'europe tu étais sortie du du bang été
enterré dans ce temps-là jeta quatre
pattes au bord du terrain il me disait
gros qu'on rentre dans ta niche voyez la
nature de nos relations mais avec de
l'humour le communiqué de l'elysée salue
son ambition son énergie et son
enthousiasme qui furent une source
d'inspiration pour des générations de
français il y aura un rassemblement
populaire et puis il y aura ensuite un
hommage officiel c'est normal que la
ville lui rendent hommage c'est sa vie
il a choisi de venir se faire inhumer
ici chanteurs acteurs
et puis quelques temps mr tron beaucoup
dans merde mais
ça valait le détour
première image qui me vient c'est celle
du combattant pour ses idées ses
convictions
je rappelle qu'il a toujours été très
engagé contre l'extrême droite tu lui
aussi d'un combattant en particulier
contre le front national le
rassemblement national il a toujours été
très attentive et je parle que d'eux
lors de nos derniers rendront à chaque
fois il est reclus ce risque là il pesé
sur les français vont nous donner les
chiffres des contaminés mais là c'est
pareil ce matin ça casse pour cent à la
une du parisien le virus progresse j'ai
repéré la maladie et nous allons la
combattre parce que ça s'appelle
l'arrivée de la peste brune
d'aventuriers du repli du rejet du
racisme
du racisme qui cite les grands auteurs
comme certains font de la prose mais qui
donne des boutons aux historiens non
monsieur zemmour il suffit pas de cité
talleyrand toutes les trois phrases pour
faire de vous un homme d'état unique
hull chroniqueur de sa propre névroses
ils pensent que tout tourne autour de
l'islam il est un raciste il a été
condamné pour ça et ils se piquent
d'histoire c'est pas moi qui vais donner
diction parce que je ne suis pas un
puits de science je sais juste que
régulièrement il se plante et que ce
type est une fraude je me sens un peu
responsable
je lui dans mon laboratoire pendant
presque cinq ans est mort et c'est
l'impression que j'ai laissé échapper
c'est un peu comme si j'avais bouffer du
poids gaulle a alors qu en plus j'aime
pas ça le pont voilà filet moore se
qualifie
candidats au deuxième tour je voterai
pour les mots
le prix cor bail pour lui quoi zemmour
montils parce que nous sommes absents
nous sommes absents du débat on n'arrête
pas de se disputer de se chamailler
comme des sous chefs de bureau eric
zemmour al'avantage la nouveauté il
arrive il est dépendant et les
percutants et il ya ce risque ou un
petit peu
vous avez en partie des républicains qui
a fait une croix définitive sur le
centre droit ils ont d'ailleurs exclu
les militants les sympathisants
centristes de leur congrès ils se
replient sur eux-mêmes ils font la
course derrière eric zemmour et ça je
pense que c'est mortifère aussi on peut
re ils sont pusillanime je les ai
traités de chochotte rae l'air et ils ne
s'en sont pas remis mais c'est quand
même ce qu'ils sont depuis 40 ans
monsieur j'ai pas peur de vous et comme
je dis je c'est des millions de gens
derrière moi et j'ai le prénom que je
veux et c'est pas parce que tu
t'appelles eric que tu va
m'impressionner